the movie opens in the late Ming Dynasty
where a woman named Mrs ba is giving
birth to her ninth child as soon as her
husband hears the baby cry he rushes
inside with excitement however his
expression quickly changes when he
discovers that it's a girl once again
just like the previous eight children
nonetheless the youngest daughter is
thrilled and she rushes to the riverbank
to share the news with her sisters a
group of eight boys are also there and
they mock the girls for not having any
brother you're not even boys you losers
these eight boys are orphans who were
raised by a former Shaolin monk named
Tien long and his younger brother y long
after rescuing them from murderous
Bandits since then the children regard
Tian long as their father and Yong as
their Uncle the baow and long families
are Fierce Rivals due to their differing
martial arts Styles the girls are
trained in the wuang clan sword handling
techniques while the boys are learning
to master the Shaolin Kung Fu the
mischievous San long the eldest of the
long children enjoys teasing sanfang the
third sister in the bow family she is
more like a tomboy in her late teens
with a fiery temper enraged by the
mockery sanfang grabs a long stick to
teach them a lesson but the boys don't
stop they even start singing a song
about her being a tomboy on the other
hand Tian long instructs his brother to
deliver some beef to the baow family for
Mrs Ba's recover y he long isn't happy
about this fearing that he will not get
married at this rate because a bride
costs 10 cows and they have saved only
three in over a decade in response
tianlong optimistically claims that the
past 6 months have been great and now
they can afford a whole leg of beef
later on Mr baow talks to his eight
daughters about their ninth sister and
expresses his disappointment in their
mother for not providing him with a son
to carry on their family Legacy sen Fang
confidently asserts that she is is just
as capable as any boy and can continue
the family's Legacy herself her two
older sisters find this amusing and
giggle at the thought of sanfang
becoming the heir or getting married
upon hearing this Mr baow tells them
that he won't allow any of his daughters
to marry the shin boys he believes the
only reason the boys are interested in
his girls is because they want to steal
their unique sword fighting style and
not because they want to show them their
own on the other side of the river the
long boys are seen practicing their Kung
Fu techniques under the supervision of
the stern Tian long however the boys
find his strictness quite challenging so
they gossip about him behind his back
later that evening Tian long enters the
boys' quarters and puts them to bed with
love this makes the boys feel bad about
their earlier gossip as a result they
apologize to him admitting their mistake
in response Tian long says that they
talk that way because he's not their
biological father he recounts an
incident from the past sharing how he
and his brother rescued them from the
bandits this heartfelt story brings
tears to the boy's eyes and they bow
before him sincerely apologizing for
their earlier gossip elsewhere the
ruthless Bandits who had orphaned the
eight long boys have been secretly
training for 10 years in order to exact
Vengeance they are still waiting for the
right time to launch an attack on the
baow family and capture the girls a
crosseyed member of the bandits comes up
with an idea given the long and bow
family's long-standing rivalry he
proposes that they can easily manipulate
them into fighting each other thus
weakening both sides before executing
their attack and the rest listen to him
too with eyes like that he can clearly
see the future as the first step of this
plan the cross-eyed Bandit kills a
priest and takes his place that same
night Mr baow visits the nearby Temple
to pray for a baby boy while he is doing
so he crosses paths with the disguised
priest the latter strikes up a
conversation and claims that Mr baow is
unable to Father a son because the long
boys are stealing his masculinity the
next day the long boys are talking to
each other when they realize that if one
of Mr Bow's daughters marry as a member
in their family they can also learn
sword skills to make this happen San
long decides to make amends with San
Fang he apologizes for their past
teasing and convinces her to persuade
her older sister Tai Fang to marry their
father the boys then steal their
father's fancy outfit and sandong wears
it before heading to the opposite side
of the river on their way they see their
Uncle meeting taii Fang on a bridge it
turns out that Yong has a crush on her
which is why he is determined to save
the cows their meeting is soon disrupted
by San Fang's arrival urging her sister
to return home Yong tries to stop her
but sanfang has a sword with her and she
points at the sign that says no Shaolin
shall pass this point helpless Yong
returns back and soon after sanlong
approaches sanfang to offer his
apologies when she remains uninterested
he jumps into the Forbidden area making
her even more Furious she then pulls out
her sword and starts attacking him
seeing this song also abandons their
original plan and engages in a battle
eventually sanfang falls into the water
leaving her Sisters in distress because
she cannot swim when s long realizes
this he quickly dives into the water and
takes her out however she is still
unconscious so everyone urges him to
blow some air in her mouth sanlong
obliges without thinking twice and is as
soon as he does so sanfang wakes up and
runs away later that evening the boys
are impressed by San Fang's sword
handling skills and they wonder how
powerful they can become if the two
skills are combined the next day sanong
approaches sanfang holding a white flag
saying that he's not there to fight but
to apologize to her he then suggests
that they can teach each other their
skills which could be beneficial to both
of them sanfang agrees to watch the demo
after which San long starts showing some
of his moves however when when it's time
for sanfang to demonstrate her skills
she declines and walks away despite this
sanlong considers it a victory Because
he believes that she's taken an interest
in their Kung Fu his assumption turns
out to be correct as sanfang is later
seen practicing Kung Fu moves on her own
meanwhile at home Mr ba tries to
persuade his wife to have one more child
10th times the charm baby come on now
when he keeps insisting Mrs ba agrees on
one condition he will allow one of their
daughters to get married to the long
family despite insufficient bride price
the scene then fast forwards 9 months
and the baow family welcomes their 10th
child finally it is a boy and Mr baow is
over the moon oh man he's got a penis in
everything later he hosts a grand party
and even invites the long boys amidst
the joyful celebration Mrs baow asks
yeong to visit their place later with
only four cows as a dowy she actually
wants him to marry one one of her
daughters the next day Tian long Yong
and song head to the Bow's residence
with their cows on their way they see a
man named Mr mauo and his son who are
also on Route with 10 cows upon arriving
at the bow household the long family
offers four cows in exchange for Mr Ba's
second daughter Tai Fang Mr baow is
furious and declines to accept such a
low price but Mrs baow reminds him of
their deal a short while later Mr Mau
arrives and offers 10 fat CS for
marriage with a big smile on his face Mr
baow agrees to give Tai Fang to him but
Mr mau's son actually wants sanfang this
shocks the girl but she knows that she
can't go against her father's wishes
hence she agrees to the marriage on the
condition that the guy must defeat her
in a duel soon the fight begins and
everyone expects the guy to emerge
Victorious however to their shock
sanfang overpowers him in no time this
effectively cancels the wedding as Mr
bow doesn't want his daughter to get
married to a freaking loser following
this the topic of Tai Fang's marriage
with Yong is once again brought back Mr
ba imposes the requirement that the
bride must be a good singer as his
daughter is fond of Music hearing this
sanlong becomes Furious and accuses Mr
bow of setting impossible conditions as
an excuse to cancel the marriage Tian
long also gets increasingly annoyed so
he walks away from there following this
rejection he declares that no one in the
long family will ever get married he
also shaves everyone's head determined
to live like Buddhist monks although the
orphan boys are happy to play along Yong
refuses to give up on Tai Fang sanong
who feels bad for his uncle devises a
plan he disguises himself as Bow's new
Ma and sneaks into their household there
he meets tyang and asks her to elope
with his uncle she instantly agrees as
she too has feelings for Yong later as
the two of them are on their way sen
Fang intercepts them but she decides to
turn a BL Blind Eye to make her sister
happy unfortunately the crosseyed Bandit
spots them and he has trouble turning a
blind eye so he immediately notifies Mr
ba and the other villagers moments
before being apprehended sanlong and Tai
Fang managed to swim across the river
but sanfang is detained the following
morning she is prepared for the
punishment for helping the Sinners elope
the punishment is to drown the culprit
to death Mrs ba begs her husband to
reconsider his DEC ision but he opts to
follow the law right before sanfang is
thrown into the water sanlong arrives at
the scene and turns himself in admitting
that it's his fault unfortunately this
turns out to be a bad decision as now
both of them are going to be punished
together the two are then tied to a
casket ready to be drowned however Mr
bow has a last minute change of heart so
he pulls the casket up much to his shock
the casket is empty it turns out San
long has saved sanfang and taken her to
a hidden cave in the aftermath sanlong
prepares food and brings it to sanfang
she expresses her gratitude for saving
her life and the two finally resolve
their longtime gaps as their
conversation unfolds sanfang agrees to
teach him some sword handling techniques
yeah she does however their happy time
is shortlived because the crosseyed man
learns about their whereabouts and
informs them to Mr bow enraged he storms
toward the cave to take his daughter
fearing for her safety samlon tries to
stop Mr ba which results in an intense
confrontation between the two but soon
after Tian long arrives on the scene and
stops his boy allowing Mr baow to leave
with his daughter in the next scene two
young long boys are playing in the water
when they notice the crossy Bandit
fleeing with a bag they follow him into
the cave where they try to distract the
Bandit in the midst of this they managed
to open the bag and are shocked to
discover Mr Bow's baby boy inside
realizing that the Bandit is is
kidnapping the infant the youngsters try
to fight him not long after Yong shows
up and engages in a physical altercation
with the Bandit however the latter
somehow manages to get away meanwhile
the bow family is deeply concerned about
their missing child they assume that
they are cursed after all these years
they finally gave birth to a boy only
for him to go missing but after a while
sanlong and the others return with the
baby boy providing them with immense
relief however the cross-eyed Bandit
once again decides to cause problem
problems he tricks Mr baow into thinking
that the boys were the one who abducted
his son Furious Mr baow berates all of
them and sternly warns them never to set
foot in the bow residence again with
their evil plan now successful the
crosseyed Bandit summons the rest of his
gang to launch an assault on the bow
family and capture all the girls the bow
family desperately tries to fight The
Intruders but the enemy forces outnumber
them significantly Mr baow gets injured
and is on the verge of defeat but at
this crucial moment the long family
shows up to support the boughs by
combining their martial arts expertise
the once rival families team up and
roundly defeat and kill all the
remaining bandits in the final scene we
see that the two rival families have
finally reconciled and the movie ends
with yeong marrying Tai Fang subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching